FILIP KNAPIK: Hi.
I'm happy to present new updates
and exciting announcements
for serverless workflows
in Google Cloud.
My name is Filip Knapik,
and I'm a product manager
working on workflow products.
Workflows is a very broad term.
Let's us first look
into some use cases
and needs around them.
Let's imagine an
e-commerce application,
a workflow that needs to
orchestrate a couple of steps--
for instance, first, create an
invoice, then generate a PDF,
and then send it to a
customer over email.
You want a workflow
product, not only
to manage and orchestrate
execution of those steps,
but also, for instance,
recover from errors
that those steps may encounter.
Another use case that you may
want to manage with a workflow
product is processing of a
batch of transactions or events
or customer records, and
then for each of those,
you may want to look
into the contents
and make a decision
on whether to take
a path with additional steps--
like, for instance, you're
looking into business
transactions,
checking if they're
overdue, and if so,
sending a reminder to
affected users or customers.
But workflows don't
have to be focused
on business transactions only.
They can also help in
automation of IT landscape.
Like, for instance, you want
to start a virtual machine,
then wait for some time, check
whether specific conditions are
met-- like, for instance,
application is up and running--
and if so, take an action, and
if not take another action.
And obviously, there
is many other use cases
in IT automation
space and others,
and workflow
products are expected
to be very flexible
in automating work
across different types
of endpoints and APIs.
Now, what do all those
use cases have in common?
There is a set of
foundational needs
that a product needs
to support in order
to enable implementation of
a workflow in a production
environment.
The first and probably
most important
element is reliable
execution of steps.
Again, in the business scenario,
in the production deployment,
we can't afford to fail
an execution of a workflow
just because there was a
temporary network outage,
and a single step was
affected, and a single step
wasn't properly executed.
And as such, a
workflow product needs
to be able to recover
from some of those errors,
and handle exceptions
or retry steps as needed
to maximize the chance
of successful execution.
Another feature that
a workflow product
needs to have is efficient
handover of the work.
And it's not only handover
of the work and orchestration
of steps.
What a workflow product
also needs to provide for
is transition and handover of
the data between those steps,
because individual
steps can produce data
that other steps may rely
on in their execution.
The decision execution
is another aspect
that is important for
workflow products.
Imagine that you're building
a workflow that is processing
your orders, or orders
from your customers,
and you want to execute a
different path if an order
exceeds a specific threshold.
Let's say beyond
or above $1,000,
you want to assign a
sales engineer or sales
specialist to that
customer to assist them,
because the deal is so big.
And in order for you to
implement such decisions
as part of your
workflow directly,
you want to have a feature that
allows you to manage execution
in a different way, provided
that specific conditions
are met.
Workflows don't always
integrate APIs or products
of the same type.
You may want to orchestrate work
across different products using
different API languages,
using different HTTP
methods, different
authentication models, or even
host it in different places.
And a workflow
product needs to be
able to integrate them all,
regardless of their diversity
and differences
in implementation.
Last but not least
of the features
that I would like to call
out is a holistic perspective
on execution and management
of your workflows.
First of all, imagine that a
third step of a workflow fails.
You need to be
able to understand
what was the business
transaction that this step
failed in to be able
to recover from it,
or you may also need to see
how many workflow executions
you had for a specific customer,
or in a specific domain.
All those features are very
important for a workflow
product.
And when looking
into those, we have
realized that our
customers would greatly
benefit from an introduction
of a serverless workflow
orchestration product
as part of Google Cloud.
And with that, I'm very happy
to announce a new product
in Google Cloud
family, Workflows.
What this product is
expected to address
is orchestration and integration
of different types of APIs.
First of all, integration of
serverless compute products.
Let's say you want to
create a workflow consisting
of different cloud
functions, and you
want to effectively
and efficiently handle
the work over in between them.
This is a great use
case for Workflows,
or the same for Cloud Run.
But we don't want to stop here.
You can also create a workflow
that, for instance, reads
the data from Firestore, or
pushes a message to Pub/Sub,
or doing any other operation
in other Google Cloud APIs.
And this is also
not where we want
it to stop, because
we understand
that our customers are running
in hybrid environments,
and often rely on, for instance,
software as a service APIs,
hosted externally to our
cloud, and therefore,
Workflows products also
support direct calls
to external APIs as part
of the workflow definition,
including all of the handling of
errors, retries, and everything
around it.
So this product is expected
to help our customers
in orchestration of work
across, practically speaking,
any of the APIs within
Google Cloud or external,
and integration of those
APIs in a holistic way
to enable implementation
of workflows.
The product is fully
managed and fully automated.
We want our customers to
focus on their business
logic of the workflow rather
than focusing on the underlying
infrastructure.
Customers are not expected,
in case of Workflows,
to look into the storage
or think about patching
of the underlying components.
This is all taken care of.
Another element that is fully
taken care of is the scale.
Regardless if you need
to run one workflow
execution per week, one per
day, or 1,000 per second,
we got it covered.
The product automatically
scales, and it also scales down
to 0, which means
that if you're not
running your workflows
for some time,
you don't have any
executions, your cost
is also going down to 0.
We assume that some of our
customers may want to use
Workflows in
latency-sensitive workloads--
for instance, having
a customer, having
a user waiting on the other side
of the screen for an outcome
of a workflow execution.
To support those cases, we have
engineered the product in a way
that step transitions
are very quick,
so that we don't introduce
unnecessary latency
in the execution of
a business workflow.
We have also taken
care of time it
takes to start a new
workflow execution,
and there is no
so-called "cold start."
So what that practically means
is that starting a new workflow
execution is not
only quick, but also
predictable and deterministic.
The product comes with
built-in security features--
first of all, you cannot make
unauthenticated requests,
so there is no
risk of somebody--
for instance, a bad
actor, or somebody
accidentally calling
out your workflow
and starting the execution
when not expected.
The product also comes
with full integration
with identity and
access management
of Google Cloud,
which means that you
can use it to orchestrate the
work of other Google Cloud
products with built-in
authentication,
without worrying about tokens
and other elements related
to authentication to those.
If you need to make
requests to external APIs
and you need to manage secrets
or passwords accordingly,
you can use Secrets Manager
for this integration,
and make secure calls to
external APIs, as well.
And obviously, the product
comes with encryption at rest
and in transit, provided that
you are using HTTPS endpoints.
By now, you are
probably wondering,
how do I model a workflow?
Can you show me an
example of how to do this?
And here it comes.
On the left-hand
side, we're seeing
an example of the
workflow, which
consists of first a call
to a cloud function,
and then based on the outcome
of that called function,
we're checking a condition
where a transaction
number is greater than 100.
And if so, we want to trigger
an execution of a Cloud Run
deployment.
Otherwise, we do not.
The right-hand side is
showing the source code
that implements this specific
workflow in our product.
So the first step is making
a call to a Cloud Function
as part of HTTP GET request, and
we're also passing some inputs
to that specific function.
We're also saying
that we want to have
the outcome of that step start
in metric result variable.
This is a workflow variable
we're going to use later on.
In the second step
of the workflow,
we have a conditional statement,
which checks whether a value--
in this case,
transaction number,
which is an outcome
of the first step--
is greater than 100.
And if so, we're making a call
to our Cloud Run deployment
using HTTPS POST method.
And by the way, we're
also passing the outcome
of the first step to the
second step as part of the call
to this Cloud Run deployment.
So this is a short
example, but this is just
to show you how you can model
a workflow using our syntax,
using our language.
We took a lot of effort to
ensure that this language is
as brief, as clear to read
and write in as possible,
to give the maximum
benefit to our developers.
Let's have a quick look
at a demo of our product.
Let's imagine that
we want to build
an e-commerce workflow that
sends an invoice to a customer.
The input to the workflow
will be an ID of a user
that we want to perform
this operation for.
The first step of
the workflow we'll
be reading a record
for that specific user
from our Firestore database.
If the amount due
equals to 0, we
are finishing the
execution at this point,
because there is nothing to do.
Otherwise, we want to
generate an invoice
and send it over as an email.
We're going to use a Cloud
function to generate an invoice
as a PDF, and then
we want to make
a request to an external
service to send an email.
Since this is an
external service,
we first need to
retrieve a secret
to be able to authenticate
to that service.
Let's see how this could be
implemented in our product.
The source code of the
workflow is a YAML structure.
In the first step
of the workflow,
we're making a request
to Firestore API,
passing an argument,
being an ID of a user,
and reading it
from the database.
This obviously needs to be
an authenticated request,
as otherwise, Firestore
wouldn't let us read anything,
and this is what these two lines
of the workflow code to do.
Whatever the output
is of that step
is stored in a user
record variable.
In the next step
of the workflow,
we're going to check whether a
specific field in the response,
amount due, equals to 0.
Now, the response of the
first step was a JSON string,
and workflow engine
is smart enough
to convert that
into a dictionary
that we can use to validate
whether the amount matches
our expectations.
If this condition is met,
the workflow the execution
finishes, with no
amount due message.
Otherwise, it proceeds
to the next step,
being a function call
using a POST request,
to our PDF generator function.
Again, this is an
authenticated request,
because we don't
want our function
to be executed by anyone.
And as a request
body, we're also
passing the contents that
we want to have in our PDF
so that our function
knows what to generate.
The output of that request
is stored in a PDF output
variable, which will actually
be the contents of the PDF file
that we want to use
as an attachment.
In the next step, we're making
a request with Secrets Manager
API to read a specific secret,
in my case, called email key.
And then we're going to use
that secret in the request
to our email sending
service, and this
is what the last step
of the workflow does.
And as you can see, we're also
including here an attachment,
being the PDF output
body, which is
the response of the
function generating our PDF.
And as the very last
step of the workflow,
we are responding
with a message,
saying that the user was sent an
invoice for a specific amount.
So with that, let's test
it out, and let's see
if it actually works.
Let me first show you the
entry for a user we're
going to be testing it
for, which is smith.j.
Apparently, he has
$784 amount that we
need to send an invoice for.
And by the way, if
you're interested,
the function that we're
using to generate the PDF
is based on an
open-source package
available as a PyPy module.
So let's now execute this
workflow and see if it works.
So as an input, I'm passing
an ID of our user, smith.j,
and I'm requesting an
execution of the workflow.
As you can see, execution
state is active,
but let's refresh
and see if it's done.
Apparently, it is.
So the output of the
workflow is the user
was sent an invoice for $784,
which is what we expect,
because this is what
we saw in the database.
Now, I also happen to have an
email account for that user,
and as you can see, we
actually got an email
that we were expecting
with a PDF attachment.
Let's have a look.
And the value matches
our expectation,
because this is exactly
what we saw in the database.
So with this short demo,
you are able to see
that we are able to orchestrate
the work of different Google
Cloud products, including
Firestore, Cloud
Function, or Google
Secrets Manager,
as well as making a request
to an external service
to send our email,
and orchestration
of all of those tasks
was performed flawlessly
by Workflows.
Let's now have a look
into the pricing model.
First of all, we wanted to
design a pricing model that
follows the promise of
serverless scalability, which
means we want the cost of using
the product to grow exactly
as the usage grows.
In other words, the
moment you go down
to zero because you
have an idle period,
or you don't need to execute
a workflow for whatever
business reasons, we
don't want to charge
for this specific scenario.
And therefore, the more
you run your workflows,
the higher, obviously,
the cost will be,
following exactly your
demand and following
the growth of your business.
We differentiate two types of
steps in our pricing model.
The pricing is based on
number of executed steps
in a workflow.
Internal steps relate
to all the elements
you can call within
the Google Cloud,
like Cloud Functions
or Cloud Run
or internal variable
assignments,
or expression evaluations
within the Google Cloud workflow
product itself.
For all those
operations, the cost
is $0.01 per 1,000
steps executed.
For external requests,
which are all the HTTP
your requests going
to the outside world
to non-Google domain names,
the cost is 2 and 1/2 cents
per 1,000 steps.
For both of those types of
steps, there is a free tier.
So if you just want
to give it a try,
you want to see where this
product is capable of,
or you are a hobbyist and
you just want to try it out,
you can use a free tier and
basically get experience
from using the product,
and then decide
whether you want to move on
with further implementations.
So the free tier is 5,000
internal steps per month,
or 2,000 external
steps per month.
With this, I wanted to
very warmly invite you
all to our Beta that
is available right
now to our product
to start using it.
Let us know your feedback.
Let us know what features you
like about this product, what
features you don't
like, or what features
you feel like are missing
or are preventing you
from using this product
to a bigger extent.
We're very keen to listen
and hear your feedback,
and I'm looking forward
to more interactions.
We are also very
committed to this product.
We are going to launch it
to general availability
by the end of 2020.
With this, I wanted to thank
you very much for attention,
and wish you happy development
of Google Cloud workflows.
Thank you very much.